[Music]
in a world where movie theaters are
outrageously expensive one man is on a
mission to make it affordable for
everyone one hack at a time that's right
George Camel is back with another minute
buddy
hit the clock freaking love this guy
movie pass lets you watch up to one
movie a week at most theaters for just
10 bucks a month I don't know how
they're making money but hopefully
they're still round by the time you
watch this this guy's a good actor
sign up with sites like advanced
screenings and go Fobo to watch movies
in theatres before they even release for
free patience is a virtue it's also a
great way to save money if you just hold
your horses you can get it through red
box or rent it digitally for a fraction
of the price Plus free snacks on your
favorite couch and you get to pause for
bathroom breaks
good-looking done get discounted tickets
through wholesale clubs Triple A or
maybe even your employer and don't
forget about matinee student and senior
citizen discounts oh and avoid those
convenience fees by getting your tickets
at the theater ness of your coast avoid
absurd snack prices by eating before you
leave the house hold on stop the clock
is that guy eatin Raisinets people still
eat those yeah raisins are just grapes
you've had all their hopes and dreams
sucked out of them here's the bonus hack
for you avoid the Raisinets and throw
some M&Ms into that popcorn game-changer
anyway if you're gonna buy snacks at
least share the cost and split it with
family or friends
and there's your minute money hack Tom
Cruise would've played a better we want
to hear from you leave a comment with
your best legal ethical and practical
movie theater hacks no trolling allowed
[Music]